From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. From PRI, Public Radio International. Public Radio. Public Radio International.
来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。来自PRI，国际公共广播电台。公共广播。国际公共广播电台。
Here's the dream, expressed as concisely, I think, as anybody ever has expressed it. I hold in my hand a handwritten sign that was photocopied and pasted up around the San Francisco area. In big letters at the top it says, "Play guitar for $5." There are two underlines underneath that. Then, in smaller letters underneath, it says, "I don't give guitar lessons. I give one lesson. In that lesson, I will teach you three chords for 5 bucks. Ever see those mindless junkies up on stage banging out that pre-adolescent bull, waving their hair around, getting free drinks and other favors? Know why they're better than you? Because they know three chords, and you don't. So for a quarter of what you'd spend getting drunk and watching their crappy band, I'll teach you all you need to know. If you're sick of talking and want to start rocking, give me a call and give me a five, and I'll show you how." And then, underneath, the guy's name, Michael Dean, punk rock and roll fantasy camp, then his phone number, and the important words which follow, "Call at noon only." Underlined "only."
这就是那个梦想，我想，这是我所见过最简洁的表达。我手里拿着一张手写的告示，它被复印后贴在旧金山地区各处。顶部用大字写着：“教弹吉他，5美元”。下面画了两道横线。然后在下面用较小的字写着：“我不提供吉他课程。我只教一节课。在那节课里，我会用5块钱教你三个和弦。见过舞台上那些毫无头脑的瘾君子吗？他们在那儿弹奏着幼稚的垃圾音乐，甩着头发，喝着免费饮料，享受着各种恩惠？知道他们为什么比你强吗？因为他们懂三个和弦，而你不懂。所以，花上你去买醉看他们烂乐队演出所需费用的四分之一，我就能教你你需要知道的一切。如果你厌倦了空谈，想开始摇滚，就给我打电话，付我五块钱，我会告诉你怎么做。”在这下面，是那个人的名字，迈克尔·迪恩，朋克摇滚奇幻夏令营，然后是他的电话号码，以及后面那句重要的话：“仅限中午致电。”“仅限”下面还加了下划线。
Why I bring it up here-- by the way, from WBEZ Chicago it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. I bring it up here because this is the dream, this right here. This sums it up, the dream of what we want when we start taking classes. Our dream is it's going to be easy, it's going to be quick, it's going to be cheap, and that we're going to be transformed by someone who is completely confident of that fact. He's just going to give it to us, and then it's just going to happen. And then we're going to be done. This is the dream that we carry with us into any kind of lessons of any sort, guitar, dancing, tennis, meditation, pottery, screenplay writing.
顺便说一下，我是WBEZ芝加哥电台的艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass），这是《美国生活》。我之所以提到这个，是因为这就是梦想，就在这儿。这总结了我们开始上课时所追求的梦想。我们的梦想是：它将变得简单、快捷、便宜，并且我们将被一位对此深信不疑的人所改变。他会直接把技能传授给我们，然后奇迹就会发生。然后我们就大功告成了。这就是我们带着去参加任何课程的梦想，无论是吉他、舞蹈、网球、冥想、陶艺还是剧本写作。
Well, we are back here on our program for another week documenting everyday life in these United States. Each week, as you know, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers and documentary producers to take a whack at that theme. Today's theme is Lessons. Act One, Ski Lessons. And in that act, we are pleased to bring you Spalding Gray, a man who is sometimes called the premier teller of monologues in America.
好了，我们又回到节目中，记录美国日常生活的一周。正如你们所知，每周我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各类作家、表演者和纪录片制作人来探讨这个主题。今天的主题是“课程”。第一幕，滑雪课程。在这一幕中，我们很高兴为大家请到斯伯丁·格雷（Spalding Gray），他有时被称为美国首屈一指的独白讲述者。
Act Two, Swimming Lesson. That'll be a story from our own Scott Carrier.
第二幕，游泳课。那将是一个来自我们同事斯科特·卡里尔（Scott Carrier）的故事。
Act Three, How To Fire a Potato in a Graceful Arc 450 Feet in the Air, a lesson on that.
第三幕，如何在空中以优雅的弧线发射土豆到450英尺远，关于这个的课程。
Act Four, we'll just get to Act Four when we do. Stick around and learn, OK?
第四幕，我们到时候再看吧。留下来学习，好吗？
Yeah, you can tell we're having the big star on today because we're using the big movie music. Klieg light sweeping across the studio ceiling. I wish you could see it in here. I've got to turn this music off. Hold on for a second. I'm just going to take that out. Let me switch to another song here. Yeah,  that'll do. As I was saying, it's a great pleasure to welcome Spalding Gray to our program. Gray's probably best known for his monologue Swimming to Cambodia , which was made into a feature film a few years back. He's travelled the country for years with various monologues, Monster in a Box, Gray's Anatomy .
是的，你们能看出来我们今天请到了大牌明星，因为我们用了大片级别的音乐。克利格聚光灯扫过演播室的天花板。我真希望你们能看到。我得关掉这音乐。稍等一下。我这就把它关了。让我切到另一首歌。是的，这就行了。正如我刚才所说，非常荣幸能欢迎斯伯丁·格雷来到我们的节目。格雷可能最出名的是他的独白《游向柬埔寨》（Swimming to Cambodia），几年前被改编成了电影。多年来，他带着各种独白在全国巡回演出，比如《盒子里的怪物》（Monster in a Box）和《格雷的解剖》（Gray's Anatomy）。
If you haven't seen him, what he does is he basically just sits on stage with a table and a glass of water and some notes in the most nondescript clothes possible, clothes that make no statement at all. And he tells these stories. It's interesting, actually, for those of us who have followed Spalding Gray's work, this monologue-- it's called It's a Slippery Slope -- because unlike some of them, it's a story in which he's really transformed. At the end of the story, he is really a different person than he is at the beginning in two ways.
如果你没看过他的演出，他基本上就是坐在舞台上，放着一张桌子、一杯水和一些笔记，穿着最普通的衣服，那些衣服没有任何表达意图。然后他讲这些故事。有趣的是，对于我们这些一直关注斯伯丁·格雷作品的人来说，这篇独白——题目叫《湿滑的斜坡》（It's a Slippery Slope）——因为与他之前的作品不同，这是一个他真正发生了转变的故事。在故事结尾，他在两个方面都与开头时的那个人完全不同了。
That transformation takes two parts. One, he leaves his long-term relationship-- this woman who he's just been with for years and years and years-- for another woman and has a baby with this other woman. And the other thing is, he learns to ski. We're going to play you a long excerpt of the skiing stories he tells. Spalding Gray tells the audience that he hates lessons and school of all types, does miserably in any kind of formal learning setting. But somehow, he gets it in his head that what he wants to do is he wants to ski. Skiers just seem glorious and athletic. And he and his longtime companion, Renee, decide to take a lesson.
那种转变分为两部分。第一，他离开了他的长期伴侣——那个和他在一起生活了许多年的女人——转而与另一个女人在一起，并与那个女人有了孩子。第二件事是，他学会了滑雪。我们将为你播放他讲述的滑雪故事的长片段。斯伯丁·格雷告诉观众，他讨厌任何形式的课程和学校，在任何正式的学习环境中都表现得很差。但不知怎的，他脑子里产生了一个想法，他想滑雪。滑雪者看起来总是那么光荣且充满活力。他和他的长期伴侣蕾妮（Renee）决定去上节课。
So there we are, standing there on a beautiful, clear, cloudless spring day. And our ski professor, the instructor, comes out and announces that he used to be a heart surgeon. Now he's retired and doing what he's always really wanted to do, ski instructing. "And aren't you lucky to be here on one of the most beautiful slopes in America," so he says, "standing on 150 inches of packed powder under a cloudless, blue sky, looking out over the edge of the Grand Canyon, the rim." And so we were, and so it was spectacular.
所以我们站在那里，在一个美丽、晴朗、无云的春日。我们的滑雪教授，那位教练，出来宣布他以前是一名心脏外科医生。现在退休了，正在做他一直真正想做的事：滑雪教学。“能来到美国最美丽的斜坡之一，真是太幸运了，”他这样说，“站在150英寸厚的积雪上，在湛蓝无云的天空下，俯瞰大峡谷的边缘。”我们确实站在那里，景象十分壮观。
And we began to do the first moves, the snow plow. And we start down. It's a bit awkward, but I am staying balanced. The skis aren't splitting me too much, and Renee and everyone else in the class is doing fine. And we go into the turns for the traverse. And people are going right, left, and I find that for some reason-- I never have found out why-- I only could turn left. But I was doing that fine. I was doing these great traverses left, and snow plow down, and take the lift up, and left, and down and left. Hi, left, left.
我们开始做第一个动作，犁式滑降。我们出发了。有点别扭，但我保持住了平衡。滑雪板没有把我的腿分得太开，蕾妮和班里的其他人做得也很好。我们进入横向移动的转弯。人们向右、向左，但我发现由于某种原因——我永远没搞明白为什么——我只能向左转。但我做得很好。我做了很棒的向左横向滑行，犁式滑降，坐缆车上去，然后左转，下滑，再左转。嗨，左转，左转。
I couldn't come around right. I thought I had to think my way around into it. And Renee now has finished the lesson, is up on the porch saying, "Let's get going. We're going to miss our plane." I said, "Renee, I don't think I can go. I have to turn right on skis. I'm going to do it like you. I've got to do it." "Spald, come, there'll be another time." "What if there isn't?"
我无法向右转弯。我以为我得通过思考来引导自己转弯。现在蕾妮已经结束了课程，站在门廊上说：“我们走吧。我们要错过航班了。”我说：“蕾妮，我觉得我不能走。我得在滑雪时学会向右转。我得像你一样。我必须做到。”“斯伯丁，走吧，还有下次机会。”“如果没机会了呢？”
In the car, I am completely dejected, depressed. She's driving. I'm in a big slough. I'm in a slump, going "Oh no, failed again." We get to the Phoenix airport, and we go in. And we're just checking on the bags, and something seizes me. I just freeze up and go, "I can't. I'm not going. I can't. Wait, wait. No, no. I've got to turn right on skis. It's as simple as that. Excuse me, ma'am. Wait, no, you put the bags. Wait, ma'am. Wait, there's a motel up there, isn't there? Up at that ski slope?" "Mr. Gray, I am here to check you on for the Newark flight. I'm not a travel agent. Are you or are you not flying with us?"
在车里，我完全灰心丧气，沮丧不已。她在开车。我沉浸在巨大的挫败感中，心想：“噢，不，又失败了。”我们到了凤凰城机场，进去准备托运包。突然，某种东西攫住了我。我僵住了，说道：“我不行。我不去了。我不能走。等等，等等。不，不。我必须学会滑雪向右转。就是这么简单。抱歉，女士。等等，不，你把行李……等等，女士。等等，上面有个汽车旅馆，对吧？就在那个滑雪场上面？”“格雷先生，我在这里为您办理飞往纽瓦克的登机手续。我不是旅行社。您到底还要不要乘机？”
"I can't-- wait a minute, Renee. You go ahead. I'm going to go up there, and maybe I can go back to Davis. I don't-- oh wait, wait, wait, oh Jesus Christ. I can't--" She's going over to talk to the head stewardess saying, "I think there's someone here that should not be flying with us today." Renee leads me over meanwhile, and she saying, "What is going on?" And I said, "Renee, listen, I'm tired of being a vicarian. I want to live a life, not tell it. I don't want to do a monologue about not being able to turn right on skis. I want to just do it. I got oh--" She goes, "Time for intervention. I'm calling your brother."
“我不能——等等，蕾妮。你先走吧。我要去那里，也许我能回戴维斯。我不知道——噢，等等，等等，噢，耶稣基督。我不能——”她走过去跟首席空姐说：“我想这儿有个人今天不应该跟我们一起飞。”与此同时，蕾妮把我带到一边，说：“到底怎么回事？”我说：“蕾妮，听着，我厌倦了做一个旁观者。我想过生活，而不是讲述生活。我不想再表演一个关于滑雪无法向右转的独白了。我想亲自去做到。我——”她说：“干预时间到了。我要给你哥哥打电话。”
She calls my brother, Rocky, in Saint Louis and says, "I'm here in the Phoenix airport. Spald won't get on the plane because he can't turn right on skis. I'll put him on. All right." "Hi, Rock, I'm doing well turning left. I know I could be a skier. Yeah, I can't turn right." "Well, don't you have a hard life."
她给住在圣路易斯的哥哥洛基（Rocky）打电话说：“我现在在凤凰城机场。斯伯丁不肯上飞机，因为他滑雪没法向右转。我会让他上去的。好的。”“嗨，洛克，我左转做得很好。我知道我能成为一名滑雪者。是的，我就是没法向右转。”“好吧，你的人生还真是艰难啊。”
Well, as this story goes, Spalding Gray does in fact get on the plane and does return to New York City. But he remains obsessed with this idea that he is going to learn to ski, and he is going to finally turn right. And so obsessed with it, in fact, he says at one point he actually starts to watch skiing videos.
好吧，正如故事所言，斯伯丁·格雷确实上了飞机，回到了纽约市。但他仍然痴迷于学习滑雪的念头，并且一定要学会向右转。事实上，他甚至到了痴迷的地步，他说有一次他真的开始看滑雪视频了。
They're unbelievable. They're like porn films. I mean similar exhibitionistic gymnastics, similar music, similar vicarious, "god, I feel lonely, I wished I was in the center of that" feeling.
它们太不可思议了。就像色情片一样。我是说，同样的炫技体操，同样的音乐，同样的代入感，“天哪，我觉得好孤独，真希望我就在那中心。”那种感觉。
Eventually, Spalding Gray does finally get to ski with an acquaintance named Barney on this picture perfect day out on a mountain in California.
最终，斯伯丁·格雷终于在加利福尼亚的一座山上，在完美的一天里，和一个叫巴尼（Barney）的熟人一起滑雪。
DayGlo tape is pulled. Barney and I start up with all of the locals. And we begin to ski, and I find I'm only going left. I'm going left into the bushes, coming out the other side with branches in my mouth like a Botticelli. And I say, I won't, I won't, I won't, I won't bother you. I know I have to do this on my own. You go ski. I'm going over to Meadow. I go over to Meadow, the green slope. And I am inspired that day when I see what I see. It's the adaptive ski school. And they are taking quadriplegics out of wheelchairs and putting them in gondolas with those little ski runners. And they have poles with skis on them, and I think, Spalding, if you can't turn right on this slope today, give it up.
日光胶带被拉开了。巴尼和我与当地人一起出发。我们开始滑雪，我发现我还是只能向左转。我左转冲进了灌木丛，另一边出来时嘴里挂着树枝，活像波提切利的画中人。我说：“我不会，我不会，我不会打扰你们的。我知道我得自己完成。你们去滑吧。我要去梅多（Meadow），那条绿色雪道。”那天我看到的景象让我备受鼓舞。那是残疾人滑雪学校。他们把四肢瘫痪的人从轮椅上抱下来，放进带有小型滑雪板的缆车里。他们有装在杆子上的滑雪板，我想：“斯伯丁，如果你今天在这一条雪道上都不能向右转，那就放弃吧。”
Now, I have no instructor. I'm trying to do this on my own. And I begin, and I'm left in crashing. And yard sale, all stuff is all over, picking up my stuff. But you know what I'm impressed by is how wildly I can crash and still get up without anything broken. And it's left and crash, and left and crash. And then it happens. It's ineffable. I can't tell you how it happens. All the time, I think I had to think myself around. It was just a shift of weight, and I never experienced this in my life except in 1946 on Thanksgiving Day when I first learned how to pump on a swing. I suddenly turned right, or something turned me right. And then left, right, left, boom, down. But I was up again, left, right, left. People would ski by me real fast. I'd crash. People would ski by me and fall. I'd crash. I was in such empathy. Or I'd be skiing and thinking, you're doing it. You're skiing. Crash. It was so beautiful. It was like zen, but not as subtle.
现在，我没有教练。我试着独自完成。我开始了，不停地左转然后摔倒。现场一片狼藉，所有的东西到处都是，我不得不捡起我的装备。但你知道吗，让我印象深刻的是，即使我摔得那么惨，我竟然还是能站起来，而且什么也没摔断。就是左转然后摔倒，左转然后摔倒。然后奇迹发生了。那感觉无法言喻。我无法告诉你它是怎么发生的。我一直以为我得靠思考来引导自己转弯。这只是一个重心的偏移，我这辈子从没体验过，除了1946年感恩节那天，我第一次学会如何在秋千上用力摆动。我突然向右转了，或者有什么东西让我向右转了。然后是左、右、左，砰，滑下去了。但我又站了起来，左、右、左。人们从我身边飞驰而过。我摔倒了。人们从我身边滑过，摔倒了。我摔倒了。我感同身受。或者我在滑雪时想着：“你在做到了。你在滑雪。”摔倒。太美妙了。这就像禅，只是没那么微妙。
If you weren't present, you crashed, and the mountain hit you. And I realized at that point that all my life I'd been doing a kind of subtle suicide to myself. I'd always be somewhere else in my head. I was always thinking, oh, I could be there. Or I could be there. I could be there. Or I wish I was there. But now when I'm skiing, I don't have that as long as I'm skiing.
如果你不专注，你就会摔倒，然后撞上山坡。我当时意识到，我这一生都在对自己进行一种隐秘的自杀。我总是让自己在脑海中处于别的地方。我总是想，噢，我可以在那儿。或者我可以去那儿。我可以去那儿。或者我希望我在那儿。但现在当我滑雪时，只要我在滑雪，我就不会那样了。
And I'm so excited I get down to lunch to join Barney, and we go over to the blue slope. And I'm going to ski with him, and now it's a [UNINTELLIGIBLE] day. It is a perfect day that reminds me of the old days, the Thornton Burgess books my father used to read to me, The West Wind Stories when you see the cloud with a face and a wind puffing out of its lips. That's how the clouds looked. Only there wasn't wind. It was these long chains of snow flurries. And then the clouds would pass, and the bright California sun would light the packed snow. And there were furrows where other people had skied, and we were hopping through the furrows in other people's rhythm. And we were riding up. We were dancing in the day. I was with a man, and we weren't talking. We were skiing together, and I couldn't stop. At the end of the day, they had to restrain me. I tried to bribe the lift operator for another run. Barney said, "Easy, easy, easy. You've been skiing for seven hours." I'd never done anything for seven hours in my life. I never thought of death once.
我太兴奋了，下山去吃午饭，和巴尼会合，然后我们要去蓝色雪道。我要和他一起滑，现在是一个[无法听清]的日子。这是一个完美的日子，让我想起了过去，我父亲过去读给我的桑顿·伯吉斯（Thornton Burgess）的书，《西风故事》，书里你可以看到一张有脸的云，风从嘴唇中喷涌而出。云就是那样看的。只是没有风。是一长串飞舞的雪花。然后云朵散去，明亮的加州阳光照亮了坚硬的积雪。那里有别人滑过留下的雪槽，我们跳进别人的节奏里滑行。我们往上坐缆车。我们在白天跳舞。我和一个男人在一起，我们没说话。我们一起滑雪，我停不下来。那天结束时，他们不得不拦住我。我试图贿赂缆车操作员让我再滑一趟。巴尼说：“冷静，冷静，冷静。你已经滑了七个小时了。”我这辈子从没做过任何持续七个小时的事。我一次都没想过死亡。
We went back to the condo. Barney was driving. I was flat-lining. Whoa, not an anxious thought in my head. Oh, boy, unwind in front of the gas log. Have a couple of beers and watch the weather channel. Whatever. Deep, deep dreamers, oblivion, sleep.
我们回到了公寓。巴尼在开车。我彻底虚脱了。哇，我脑子里没有任何焦虑的想法。噢，伙计，在燃气壁炉前放松一下。喝两杯啤酒，看气象频道。不管怎样。深沉的、深沉的梦想，遗忘，睡眠。
The following day, I woke up and I thought, oh, my god. Now there's skiing, and there's life. And I don't want to live anymore. I don't want to come down from this mountain. I want to figure out how to stay up here, how to make a living up here, how to just ski. I had a mission. I never felt a mission in my life, a quest. I wanted to ski across America to New England. I saw myself like John Cheever's story, "The Swimmer." Burt Lancaster did the film. Swimming his way back to that deserted house through backyard swimming pools, only I was going to do it on ski slopes and use my monologue as a vehicle and begin booking them by ski areas.
第二天醒来，我想，噢，天哪。现在有滑雪，还有生活。我不想再活下去了。我不想从这座山上下来。我想弄清楚怎么能一直待在这上面，怎么能在这上面谋生，怎么能就这样一直滑下去。我有一个使命。我这辈子从没感觉到什么使命，一种追求。我想滑雪横跨美国到达新英格兰。我把自己想象成约翰·契弗（John Cheever）的小说《游泳者》里的主角。伯特·兰卡斯特（Burt Lancaster）演过那部电影。他通过后院的游泳池游回家，只不过我是要在滑雪道上完成，把我的独白当作交通工具，开始预订滑雪区的场地。
And I did. I booked Gray's Anatomy first of all where I had to conquer the big master, Ajax in Aspen. And I booked the Wheeler Opera House, and they gave me a condo, a free ski lesson, and passes to ski and some money. It was a very good deal. It was. And basically in Aspen, there are two mountains. You've got Ajax, the big, giant father figure. And then you've got Buttermilk, which is like the reclining lady. You can ski over her breasts and through her thighs, no problem. At the end of the day, go over and get beat up by the father, you see. The ticket is interchangeable.
我确实做了。我预订了《格雷的解剖》，首先我必须征服那个大主人，阿斯彭（Aspen）的埃阿斯山（Ajax）。我预订了惠勒歌剧院（Wheeler Opera House），他们给了我一间公寓，一节免费滑雪课，滑雪通行证和一些钱。这是一个非常好的交易。确实如此。基本上在阿斯彭，有两座山。你有埃阿斯山，那个巨大的、强壮的父亲形象。然后你有白脱牛奶山（Buttermilk），就像一位侧卧的女士。你可以滑过她的乳房，穿过她的大腿，没问题。一天结束时，再去那边被父亲修理一顿，你看。票是通用的。
So I am having my ski lesson on Buttermilk, of course, on the lady. And I am hanging out, waiting for the ski instructor to come out. I have nothing to do, so I'm reading whatever I can get my hands on. I'm reading the back of my ski ticket. I will never do that again. "Skiing is inherently a dangerous sport, which can result in personal injury, including catastrophic injury, death or property damage." God forbid property damage. "If you are not willing to assume the risks set forth in this warning, please do not ski in this area." Sign it. Sign the ticket. Sign for the skis, little stubby 160s so I can turn easily. Sign, sign, sign. Sign my life away and wait for my ski instructor to come out.
所以我的滑雪课是在白脱牛奶山上，当然，是在那位女士身上。我在闲逛，等滑雪教练出来。我没事干，所以我在读所有能拿到的东西。我在读滑雪票的背面。我再也不会那样做了。“滑雪是一项固有的危险运动，可能导致人身伤害，包括灾难性的伤害、死亡或财产损失。”上帝保佑，千万别财产损失。“如果您不愿意承担此警告中规定的风险，请不要在此区域滑雪。”签名。在票上签名。在滑雪板上签名，那种160厘米的小短板，好让我容易转弯。签名，签名，签名。签署我的生命，等待我的滑雪教练出来。
And he skis out, says, "Hi, guy. OK, let's begin. Sterling, is it all right if I call you Sterling? Let's begin with a little joke, Sterling. Do you know the difference between a snowboard and a vacuum cleaner?" "No, I don't." "Depends on where you attach the dirt bag. OK, slight bend in the knees. Corresponding bend in the hip joint, great. OK, crouch and lift at the same time, good. Parallel skis, flat on the snow. Skis slightly edged, all right? Now, using turns on each traverse, we can go down the mountain at any speed we so desire. Now weight, 90% of the weight on the downhill ski, good. Weight forward, don't sit back. Nothing natural about this posture, Sterling, nothing natural about it. Hey, don't cave in. All right, flex your elbows. Weight over the balls of your feet. Please don't stick your butt out.
他滑了出来，说：“嗨，伙计。好吧，让我们开始吧。斯特林（Sterling），我可以叫你斯特林吗？我们先开个玩笑，斯特林。你知道滑雪板和吸尘器有什么区别吗？”“不，我不知道。”“看你把脏物袋装在哪儿。好吧，膝盖微屈。髋关节相应弯曲，太棒了。好的，下蹲和抬起同时进行，很好。滑雪板平行，放平在雪地上。滑雪板稍微侧边，好了？现在，在每次横向滑行中使用转弯，我们可以以我们想要的任何速度滑下山。现在重心，90%的重量放在下坡的那块板上，很好。重心前移，不要向后坐。这种姿势一点也不自然，斯特林，一点也不自然。嘿，不要塌下去。好了，肘部弯曲。重心放在脚掌上。请不要把屁股撅出来。”
Now, your basic traverse stance is often referred to as that of a banana. Banana arching, skin on the banana. Still think of your ski-suit as a banana skin if that's going to help. Now, you're really falling down the mountain, Sterling." Another snowboarder shoots between us. "That little [BLEEP]. I'm just waiting for one of them to hit me, and I'm going to cash in on his HMO and retire. OK, parallel skis. Upper ski is slightly leading in front of the downhill ski. Shift your weight and let the upper ski lead out. All right, facing down the fall line. Basically, you're falling down the mountain, OK? Point your belly button down the hill. Banana arching, OK? You stand and watch while I traverse down the mountain, and then you follow."
“现在，你基本的横向姿势通常被称为香蕉姿势。香蕉拱起，香蕉皮。如果这有帮助，就把你的滑雪服当作香蕉皮。现在，你真的要掉下山了，斯特林。”另一个滑雪者从我们中间冲过。“那个小[哔]家伙。我正等着他们中谁撞我一下，我就能拿他的健康保险金退休了。好吧，滑雪板平行。上方的板稍微领先于下方的板。重心偏移，让上面的板先出去。好了，面向下坡方向。基本上，你正在掉下山，明白吗？把肚脐指向山下。香蕉拱起，明白吗？你站在这儿看我横向滑下山，然后你跟着我。”
I stood there like a frozen banana and ended up going down to the Wheeler Opera House to perform Gray's Anatomy . My ironic, hypochondriacal voice made all the exhausted skiers laugh. The following day, I was determined to set skis on Ajax, even though my guide books said under no circumstances should a beginner go on this mountain. And on the way to Ajax, I was recollecting my Greek history. Ajax, hero of the Trojan Wars, who mistook a flock of sheep for warriors, hallucinated, killed them, and then killed himself out of humiliation. That's Ajax.
我像一根冷冻的香蕉一样站在那儿，最后滑到了惠勒歌剧院去表演《格雷的解剖》。我那讽刺的、疑病症式的声音让所有精疲力尽的滑雪者们大笑起来。第二天，我下定决心要在埃阿斯山上尝试，尽管我的指南书说新手在任何情况下都不应该去那座山。在去埃阿斯山的路上，我回想着希腊历史。埃阿斯，特洛伊战争中的英雄，他把一群羊错认成了战士，产生了幻觉，杀死了它们，然后因为羞辱自杀了。那就是埃阿斯。
So I arrive, and I get the map. And I'm choosing what trail I should go on based on the name. And I choose Dipsy-Doodle and Pussyfoot. So I'm standing on Dipsy-Doodle, talking to myself. Skis parallel and slightly apart. Slightly. Slightly means slightly. Relax arms, flex elbows, flex elbows. Why did I let him call me Sterling? Crouch and lift at the same time. Weight over the balls of your feet. Now look, I never knew my feet had balls. I've heard the expression, but I have never contacted them. Basically, I felt like a bad geometry class. I felt all fragmented. I couldn't really get it all together and boogie. And these these other skiers are going by me full speed, doing that little Austrian wiggle, that tight ass little bunny hop, the skis close together. [BUMPING SOUNDS] They go by. With their nose up in the air, they go, "On your left." I mean you're not allowed to fall on Ajax. If you fall, they go by and go, "On your left." At Buttermilk, they say, "Are you all right, guy? Can I help you up?"
我到了，拿到了地图。我根据名字来选择我要去哪条小径。我选了“轻快摆动”（Dipsy-Doodle）和“猫步”（Pussyfoot）。我站在“轻快摆动”上，自言自语。“滑雪板平行，稍微分开。稍微。稍微意味着稍微。手臂放松，肘部弯曲，肘部弯曲。我为什么让他叫我斯特林？下蹲和抬起同时进行。重心放在脚掌上。听着，我从来不知道我的脚还有脚掌。我听过这个说法，但我从来没感觉到它们。基本上，我觉得自己像是一节糟糕的几何课。我觉得自己都破碎了。我没法把它整合在一起跳舞。而这些其他的滑雪者从我身边全速经过，做着那种小奥地利人的摆动，那种紧绷的、兔子跳，滑雪板紧贴在一起。[撞击声] 他们经过。他们扬起鼻子，说：“从你左边过。”我是说，你不可以在埃阿斯山上摔倒。如果你摔倒了，他们会经过并说：“从你左边过。”在白脱牛奶山，他们会说：“你还好吗，伙计？我能帮你站起来吗？”
But I'm skiing. I'm skiing, and I'm going down. I haven't got any inner cheerleader voice, no voice in me saying, you're doing great. But you know what I don't have anymore? I don't have the self-deprecating, "you're [BLEEP] you're no good, you'll never master this" voice because the mountain's knocking the [BLEEP] out of me. It's hitting me. It took that voice away. It's such a whoa that beats you up. It's a plummeting. It's like the father I never wrestled with. I'm down, boom. And I'm up again. And I'm surviving it. And I'm skiing, and I experience a zen miracle. I'm hungry without looking at my watch.
但我正在滑。我在滑，我正在往下。我没有任何内心拉拉队的声音，没有声音在说，你做得很好。但你知道我不再有什么声音了吗？我不再有那种自我贬低的、“你是个[哔]，你一无是处，你永远也掌握不了这个”的声音，因为山坡正在狠狠地教训我。它在撞击我。它带走了那个声音。这是一种揍你的冲击感。这是一种俯冲。就像我从未与之角力过的父亲。我倒下了，砰。然后我又站了起来。我正在幸存。我正在滑雪，我体验到了禅宗奇迹。我不看表就饿了。
And I ski on down. I don't ski the whole mountain. It's just halfway down to the little gourmet restaurant, Bonnie's. Hey, I feel like a skier now. I can eat with them on the deck. Take my skis off, [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in the snow, clomp on down like a man on the moon, big ski boots crouching on the deck. Order a well-done hamburger to avoid E. coli. And sit out in the sun. Oh, my  god. I've got to pinch myself. The fat lady hasn't sung yet. Is this really happening to me? Is this Spuddy Gray, great failure of Barrington, Rhode Island, skiing in Aspen alone, able to be alone? It occurred to me that this was a moment I was having for myself. I was doing this. I didn't even know what that meant, never had the experience in my life. And I'm saying, this is really cool. I like this.
我继续滑下去。我没有滑完整座山。只滑了一半，到了那家小小的美食餐厅，邦尼餐厅（Bonnie's）。嘿，我现在感觉像个滑雪者了。我可以和他们坐在甲板上一起吃东西。脱掉滑雪板，[无法听清]踩在雪里，像个登陆月球的人一样沉重地走过去，巨大的滑雪靴蹲在甲板上。点一个熟透的汉堡以避免大肠杆菌。坐在阳光下。噢，天哪。我得掐自己一下。那胖女人还没开口唱歌呢。这真的发生在我身上吗？这就是斯帕迪·格雷（Spuddy Gray），罗德岛巴灵顿的伟大失败者，独自在阿斯彭滑雪，能够一个人待着？我突然意识到这是一个只属于我自己的时刻。是我在做这件事。我甚至不知道这意味着什么，我这辈子从没体验过。我说，这真的很酷。我喜欢这个。
And oh, I see three people coming toward me. Uh-oh, it's all over. These people have probably seen my show. I can tell by the way the woman's smiling. And they come over, though I like them. They're locals. The first woman's name is Maggie. She's a mail-woman, a letter carrier. She's on a long lunch break. And her boyfriend, Jake, who is a a contractor, and then Martha, a friend of theirs who is a ski instructor for the blind actually over at Buttermilk. And they're all taking the day off to ski. And they want to ski with me. And I say, "Oh, no, no, I'm not really a skier. I'm just a faller, really. I'm up here falling down. Don't, don't, don't. I'm having a good time alone. It's fine." No, no, they're not interested. They've skied the mountain hundreds of times. And Jake's trying to give me this line that pack skiing is how I will really learn, skiing in a group. He's got this theory, the Balinese dance masters, he's telling me. That's how they teach their students kinetically so they're dancing right. "All right, I'll give it a try."
噢，我看到三个人朝我走来。糟糕，全完了。这些人可能看过我的演出。从那个女人的笑容我能看出来。他们走过来，虽然我挺喜欢他们。他们是当地人。第一个女人叫玛吉（Maggie）。她是个邮递员，信使。她正在午休。还有她的男朋友杰克（Jake），是个承包商，还有玛莎（Martha），他们的朋友，其实是在白脱牛奶山教盲人滑雪的教练。他们都在休息滑雪。他们想和我一起滑。我说：“噢，不，不，我真的不是个滑雪者。我其实只是个摔跤手。我在这上面一直摔倒。别，别，别。我一个人玩得很开心。挺好的。”不，不，他们没兴趣。他们已经滑过这座山几百次了。杰克试图跟我说一套理论，说团队滑雪才是真正学习的方法，成群结队滑雪。他有这个理论，他在跟我讲巴厘岛的舞蹈大师。他们就是这样以动觉方式教学生的，让他们跳得正确。“好吧，我试试。”
So we go over, and damn it all if those skis don't feel too big. They always do when I put them on at first. I feel like a two-year-old trying to walk again. They're crossing. I'm flopping around. I fall down. They're waiting. They're laughing. They're doing fine. But damn it, Jake is right. The actor-mimic in me is able, for some reason, to connect with him and begin to ski like him, to emulate him. So my skis are more parallel. I'm getting up more speed. In fact, I'm almost-- not crashing into him, but becoming one with him until I try to get back to myself and I crash because I don't know how to make the transition.
所以我们过去了，该死的，如果那些滑雪板感觉没有太大，就不会这样。我刚穿上它们时总是觉得太大。我觉得自己像个刚学走路的两岁小孩。它们交叉了。我手忙脚乱。我摔倒了。他们在那儿等。他们在笑。他们做得很好。但该死，杰克是对的。我身上的演员模仿天赋，由于某种原因，能够与他建立联系并开始像他一样滑雪，去模仿他。所以我的滑雪板更平行了。我正在提高速度。事实上，我几乎——不是撞向他，而是与他融为一体，直到我试图找回自我，然后我摔倒了，因为我不知道该如何过渡。
But something's happening that is right. And Maggie is the provocateur. She keeps passing over a snuffed out marijuana joint that she wants to re-light every time we're on the lift. "Oh no, no, thanks. Really, that stuff just makes me think. I don't-- Well, actually think is the word. I'd be a scholar if that was the case. It just makes me grind my gears, junk-head, around and around, garbage, nothing productive. Really, I mean if I was dancing all night at a club or something, I'd take it. But--" "Oh," Maggie says, "really, Spalding, skiing is like dancing in the day. It's like dancing in the light. Don't say no. Just say maybe."
但有什么东西正在发生，那是对的。玛吉是个挑衅者。她不断递过来一支熄灭的大麻烟，每次我们在缆车上她都想重新点燃。“噢不，不，谢谢。真的，那东西只会让我思考。我不——好吧，其实思考这个词。如果真是那样的话，我就是个学者了。它只是让我的齿轮磨损，垃圾脑袋，转啊转，全是垃圾，没什么成效。真的，我是说如果我整晚在俱乐部跳舞或者什么的话，我会抽的。但是——”“噢，”玛吉说，“真的，斯伯丁，滑雪就像在白天跳舞。就像在光中跳舞。别说不。只说也许。”
So next time around, Maggie and I are alone on a double lift. And she just lights it and passes it over. And I don't think about it. I just go [INHALING SOUNDS]. Pass it back. And I begin to think. I begin to think so hard that I don't get off the lift, and it goes around. They stop it. I'm hanging up there. He goes, "Hey, rock and roll. Hey, man, having a good day?" They're helping me down, and the skis are falling off. They are too big, I'm thinking. And the marijuana is making them seem too big. But I have to say, in defense of the hemp, it really does loosen up my hips. Not that you're supposed to have loose hips when you're skiing, but boogie on down. I'm skiing with Jake now, and I like that, this new male thing, because usually I always felt I had to talk to a guy. We're just skiing together, and I'm up at the top of the mountain waiting for Martha and Maggie to come up.
所以下一次，玛吉和我单独坐在一辆双人缆车上。她直接点燃了它并递了过来。我没多想。我只是[吸气声]。传了回去。我开始思考。我开始想得如此深，以至于我没从缆车上下来，它转了一圈。他们把它停住了。他说道：“嘿，摇滚乐。嘿，伙计，今天过得开心吗？”他们帮我下来，滑雪板掉了。我觉得它们太大了，我想。大麻让它们看起来太大了。但我必须说，为大麻辩护，它确实放松了我的臀部。并不是说滑雪时你应该有放松的臀部，但跟着节奏摆动吧。我现在正和杰克一起滑，我喜欢这个，这种新的男性事物，因为通常我总觉得自己必须跟男人说话。我们只是在一起滑雪，我在山顶等着玛莎和玛吉上来。
And Jake says, "I want to show you something." Oh, god no. He's going to try to teach me something. Suddenly, I feel like a frozen banana. "No," he says, "don't freeze up. You're doing fine in your turns. But you know what? After you turn, you're sliding down the mountain. You're sliding down the mountain because you're not edging. Just watch me for a minute. And I look over. Oh, wow, I'm able to see it. I'm able to take it in. He rolls his skis in just slightly into the mountain and edges . And oh, yes, I'm behind him, and what a difference an edge makes.
杰克说：“我想给你看点东西。”噢，该死，不。他要试着教我点什么。突然间，我觉得自己又像根冷冻香蕉了。“不，”他说，“别僵住。你的转弯做得很好。但你知道吗？转弯后，你正在滑下山。你正在滑下山，因为你没有侧边用力。只要看我一分钟。”我看向那边。噢，哇，我能看到了。我能理解了。他把滑雪板稍微向山坡倾斜，侧边用力。噢，是的，我跟在他后面，侧边用力真是太不一样了。
We are skiing now down Ruthie's Run, a terrain that was so steep, I was simply crashing down it before. And now, I am realizing that you have to be out of control to be in control. For a second, you have to be falling down that fall line and then catch yourself. And you have to have the leap of faith, and I never had faith in my life until that day. You've got to believe you're going to turn right in order to turn right, and it's a leap of faith and around. Wow, I doubted everything until this moment. And a leap of faith, and I'm around. And I'm falling into the light. And I can feel the gravity pulling me, the earth, the mother. And leap of faith, and I'm around. And leap of faith, I'm around. And leap of faith, I'm around. And Maggie shoots behind me with stereo earphones on, yelling "Think of it as a white wall of death."
我们现在正滑下露丝跑道（Ruthie's Run），那里的地形太陡峭了，我之前只是摔着滑下去的。现在，我意识到你必须失去控制才能获得控制。有一秒钟，你必须沿着滚落线跌落，然后抓住自己。你必须有信仰的飞跃，而直到那天之前，我生命中从未有过信仰。你必须相信你能向右转才能真正向右转，这是一种信仰的飞跃，然后转弯。哇，直到这一刻我还在怀疑一切。信仰的飞跃，我转过来了。我正在坠入光中。我能感觉到重力拉着我，地球，母亲。信仰的飞跃，我转过来了。信仰的飞跃，我转过来了。信仰的飞跃，我转过来了。玛吉戴着立体声耳机在我身后飞驰而过，大喊着：“把它想象成一堵死亡的白墙。”
And I'm able to keep my balance in the face of this, and I know where she gets her kicks. And I know she's hoping I'll do a monologue about this, and she will be in it. We have a wonderful afternoon. It's timeless. It's so energized. It's so-- oh, it's so-- and they bid farewell. They say, "It's almost 4 o'clock. We've got to run the mountain. You download." I said, "No, I want to ski down with you guys." "Spalding, you know what? It's really not safe. There's only one way down the mountain. At the end of the trail, it's Spa Gulch. And the locals refer to that often as the valley of the shadow of death. It's icy. It's dark. The shadow comes in. Maggie blew her ACL tendons out last year. You could hear them pop up the gulch like hot spaghetti. You don't want to do it." "I do." "It's your choice."
面对这一切，我还能保持平衡，我知道她从哪儿得到的快感。我知道她希望我能对此做一个独白，而她会出现在里面。我们度过了一个美妙的下午。那是永恒的。充满了能量。那是——噢，那是——然后他们告别了。他们说：“快4点了。我们要滑下山。你坐缆车下去吧。”我说：“不，我想和你们一起滑下去。”“斯伯丁，你知道吗？这真的不安全。下山只有一条路。在小径的尽头，是温泉峡谷（Spa Gulch）。当地人通常把那里称为死亡阴影之谷。那里有冰。很暗。阴影笼罩。玛吉去年吹断了她的前交叉韧带。你能听到它们在峡谷里像热意面一样弹断的声音。你不想去那儿。”“我想去。”“那是你的选择。”
So I opt-- my plan is that I'm going to follow Martha, the blind ski instructor. I hadn't skied with her yet. Ski instructor for the blind. She was like a sleek weasel, really, really, smooth, fast, confident. And I'm right behind her. And what's exciting now is that we're running the whole mountain, so the rhythm starts to build. And before, we were just skiing around at the top. And we're starting down, and there's all this new terrain. And then, as we get closer to Spa Gulch, I can see what they mean. The conversion, it's like a LA freeway. All the trails are going into that one place. And behind me, I can hear snowboarders shredding.
所以我的计划是跟随玛莎，那个盲人滑雪教练。我还没和她一起滑过呢。盲人滑雪教练。她真的像一只光滑的黄鼠狼，非常、非常平稳、快速、自信。我就跟在她后面。现在最令人兴奋的是，我们要滑整座山，所以节奏开始建立起来了。之前我们只是在顶端滑来滑去。我们开始往下，有所有这些新的地形。然后，当我们接近温泉峡谷时，我明白他们的意思了。转换，就像洛杉矶的高速公路。所有的路径都汇集到那一个地方。在我身后，我能听到单板滑雪者在撕裂雪地。
And all of a sudden, Martha goes straight up the edge of the gulch and hops around and comes down. And I'm behind her. I don't know who's doing this. Are the skis skiing me? And I go up, and all of a sudden, I see a cobalt blue sky, a new moon, and I'm around. I see amber, bright sun on snow and dark shadow. And down and up and around, and down and up and around. And up and down and up. Pow, born out of the thighs of Ajax. And Jake comes over and gives me a big high five, my first.
突然，玛莎直接滑上峡谷的边缘，跳了一下又下来了。我跟在她后面。我不知道是谁在做这个。是滑雪板在滑我吗？我滑了上去，突然间，我看到了钴蓝色的天空，一轮新月，我转了过来。我看到了琥珀色，明亮的阳光照在雪地上，还有深色的阴影。向下，向上，向右，向下，向上，向右，又向下，向上。砰，从埃阿斯的大腿中诞生。杰克走过来，给了我一个响亮的击掌，这是我第一次击掌。
And I say, "Thank you, thank you, thank you. Thank you for skiing with me today." And I bid them farewell and go in to turn my equipment into the rental place. And the guy says, "Hey, man, you should either be dead or in the hospital." I said, "What are you talking about? You hear I skied the gulch?" "No, you stole some lawyer's 195s at lunch. He had a $125 lesson he had to take. He had to take on your stubby little 160s. He's looking for you, man. I mean, you skied on the wrong bindings all afternoon. It's a wonder you didn't break your leg. You're [BLEEP] blessed, man."
我说：“谢谢，谢谢，谢谢。谢谢你今天陪我滑雪。”我和他们道别，去租借处归还我的装备。那个人说：“嘿，伙计，你现在要么应该死了，要么在医院里。”我说：“你在说什么？你听说我滑了那个峡谷吗？”“不，你在午餐时偷了某个律师的195滑雪板。他花125美元买的课程。他不得不穿你的那种小短板160。他在找你，伙计。我是说，你整个下午都穿错了固定器在滑。你没断腿真是个奇迹。你真是[哔]受到保佑了，伙计。”
And with his blessings, I felt initiated. I skied Ajax, skied Spa Gulch and graduated in one day from 160s to 195.
带着他的祝福，我觉得自己得到了启蒙。我滑了埃阿斯，滑了温泉峡谷，并且在一天内从160毕业到了195。
Spalding Gray, an excerpt from his monologue, It's a Slippery Slope . We recorded Spalding Gray at the world premiere of his monologue at the Goodman Theatre in Chicago.
斯伯丁·格雷，选自他的独白《湿滑的斜坡》。我们在芝加哥古德曼剧院（Goodman Theatre）的独白世界首演上录制了斯伯丁·格雷的表演。
Coming up, swimming lessons, shooting potatoes 450 feet in the air, instructions on how to have an affair, and more, in a minute, when our program continues.
接下来，游泳课，在空中发射450英尺远的土豆，关于如何出轨的说明，等等，稍后节目继续。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme with monologues, short fiction, mini-documentaries, found tape, whatever they can think of. Our theme today is Lessons. We are at Act Two of our program, Swimming Lesson. You know, some lessons-- I think the best classes-- always teach more than concrete skills. They help overcome fears. They change people in more profound ways. This next story comes from Scott Carrier, who lives in Salt Lake City.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们都会选择一个主题，邀请各类作家和表演者通过独白、短篇小说、迷你纪录片、现成录音带，或者任何他们能想到的方式来探讨这个主题。我们今天的主题是“课程”。我们现在进入节目的第二幕，游泳课。你知道，有些课程——我认为最好的课程——总是传授比具体技能更多的东西。它们帮助克服恐惧。它们以更深远的方式改变人们。下一个故事来自住在盐湖城的斯科特·卡里尔。
My wife, Hillary, is a beautiful swimmer, relaxed, graceful. She just sort of slimmers around on top of the water. I didn't know this about her when I met her. I knew she grew up on a lake in New Hampshire, but I'd never seen her swim until this summer when we spent a few weeks at the lake visiting her parents. She liked to swim at night, go far out in the darkness and then turn around and swim back to the light on her parents' house.
我的妻子希拉里（Hillary），是一位漂亮的游泳者，放松、优雅。她只是在水面上轻轻滑行。我遇见她时不知道这一点。我知道她在新罕布什尔州的一个湖边长大，但我从未见过她游泳，直到今年夏天我们在湖边陪她父母待了几周。她喜欢在晚上游泳，游向黑暗的深处，然后转身游回她父母房子发出的光亮处。
So this summer, we were there at the lake, and my wife and her mother decided it was time for our three and a half-year-old daughter to take swimming lessons. I said, "No, she's too young." And my wife said, "Mr. Switzer likes to start them at three and a half." I said, "Who's Mr. Switzer?" And my mother-in-law said, "He gives lessons in the pool next to his house. It's a nice pool. He taught Hillary to swim. He taught all my kids to swim. He went to Harvard and then coached at a private school with a good reputation." I said, "Oh, well, then of course." And my wife said, "Monday morning. We've already signed her up. You can come with us and see for yourself. He's a good teacher."
所以今年夏天，我们在湖边，我妻子和她母亲决定，是我们三岁半的女儿上游泳课的时候了。我说：“不，她太小了。”我妻子说：“斯威策先生（Mr. Switzer）喜欢从三岁半开始教。”我说：“斯威策先生是谁？”我岳母说：“他在他家旁边的游泳池里教课。那是个很好的池子。他教希拉里游泳。他教了我所有的孩子游泳。他上过哈佛，后来在一家声誉良好的私立学校当教练。”我说：“噢，好吧，那当然可以。”我妻子说：“周一早上。我们已经给她报了名。你可以和我们一起去，亲眼看看。他是个好老师。”
So Monday morning, we drove to Al and Betsy Switzer's Aquatic School in Center Sandwich. The pool was dark blue, the color of glacial ice, 60 feet long and nearly ringed by mothers sitting in white, plastic lawn chairs. There were about 18 kids in the pool, a couple of pretty college girls teaching the intermediate and advanced swimmers, and Mr. Switzer, deep tan, square jaw, big muscles, in the pool at the shallow end with the beginners, three boys and three girls hanging on to the edge, crying and shivering. Or actually, it was just the three boys who were crying. One of them tried to climb out of the pool, and Mr. Switzer pulled him back in saying, "You stay there. You stay right there and don't move from that spot." That, of course, made the other two boys freak out even more, and one of them was crying for his mom to come get him. And Mr. Switzer pointed to the mom and then pointed to the gate. And she popped right up and walked out.
周一早上，我们开车去了位于中心三明治镇（Center Sandwich）的艾尔和贝特西·斯威策水上学校。游泳池是深蓝色的，像冰川冰的颜色，60英尺长，周围几乎围满了坐在白色塑料草坪椅上的母亲们。池子里大约有18个孩子，两个漂亮的大学生在教中级和高级游泳者，而斯威策先生，晒得深黑，方下巴，大肌肉，在浅水区和初学者在一起，三个男孩和三个女孩抓着边缘，哭泣和颤抖。或者说，其实只有那三个男孩在哭。其中一个试图爬出泳池，斯威策先生把他拉了回来，说：“你待在那里。你就在那儿待着，别离开那个位置。”这当然让另外两个男孩更加崩溃，其中一个哭着喊他妈妈来接他。斯威策先生指了指那位妈妈，然后指了指大门。她立刻跳了起来，走了出去。
Head down.
头朝下。
In the lesson, Mr. Switzer took the kids one by one and stood over them, moving their arms and legs through the water. He did this even to the kids who were nearly hysterical. Kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick, kick. Then he had them go under the water, keeping their eyes open to look and grab his fingers. Then he had them get out and walk over to the edge where the water was deeper. They were all standing there shaking, holding their little hands over their little hearts. He was going to make them jump.
课上，斯威策先生把孩子们一个接一个地带过来，站在他们上方，带着他们的手臂和腿在水中划动。即使是对那些几乎歇斯底里的孩子，他也这样做。踢腿，踢腿，踢腿，踢腿，踢腿，踢腿，踢腿。然后他让他们潜到水下，睁开眼睛寻找并抓住他的手指。然后他让他们出来，走到水更深的地方。他们都站在那里发抖，把小手放在小心脏上。他要让他们跳下去。
Now listen, everybody, what you're going to do is you're going to jump to me, and I'm going to catch you. All right? I'm going to catch everybody. Stand up, Alice.
现在听着，各位，你们要做的是跳向我，我会接住你们。好吧？我会接住每个人的。站起来，爱丽丝（Alice）。
First, he told my daughter to jump, and she did and just about landed on his head. She was kind of screwing around and having too much fun. Next, the other two girls, and they jumped pretty easily too. But then, the boys, and the boys were afraid. They were just little kids who hadn't learned to hide their fear, what looked like true fear, not some sudden fright caused by a bad dream or a monster movie, but scared, silly panic, their bodies quivering like jello, their faces filled with grief.
首先，他让我女儿跳，她确实跳了，差点落在他的头上。她有点在胡闹，玩得太开心了。接下来，另外两个女孩，她们也跳得相当轻松。但随后，男孩们，男孩们很害怕。他们只是还没学会隐藏恐惧的小孩，看起来是真实的恐惧，不是那种由噩梦或怪物电影引起的突如其来的惊吓，而是吓坏了，愚蠢的恐慌，他们的身体像果冻一样颤抖，脸上充满了悲伤。
Ready. I'll catch you. Come on. Go. Jump, jump. Go. Jump. Come on.
准备好。我会接住你的。来吧。跳，跳。来吧。跳。来吧。
But they did it, or at least two of them summoned their courage, leaned into their fear, and jumped. For them, it was as wild and as real as it gets. But the other little one just couldn't do it, so they pushed him.
但他们做到了，或者至少其中两个鼓起勇气，直面恐惧，跳了下去。对他们来说，这尽可能地疯狂和真实。但另一个小家伙就是做不到，所以他们推了他一把。
What did I tell you? What did I tell you? What did I tell you? What did I say? I'd catch you. Yeah, and I said I'd catch you. Did I catch you?
我跟你说过什么？我跟你说过什么？我跟你说过什么？我说什么了？我会接住你的。是的，我说我会接住你的。我接住你了吗？
Yeah.
接住了。
After the lesson, I introduced myself to Mr. Switzer and asked him about his methods.
课后，我向斯威策先生作了自我介绍，并询问了他的教学方法。
As soon as we start working the arms with a three and a half-year-old, we're basically working with the arms the way we want them to work later on. And you saw today, a couple of the real criers, they don't know what they're in for. But then they find I'm a good guy. They find that if I say I'm going to catch them or I'm going to do something, I'm not going to fool them. See, the classes you're watching this afternoon, some of those Beginner One classes, by the end of this week, they'll all go off in the deep end. And most of them will go off from the diving board, which is one meter up. And they'll swim to the ladder.
一旦我们开始和三岁半的孩子练习手臂动作，我们基本上就是按照我们希望他们以后工作的方式来练习手臂。你们今天看到了，有几个是真的大哭，他们不知道将会发生什么。但后来他们发现我是个好人。他们发现如果我说我会接住他们或者我会做什么，我就不会欺骗他们。你看，你们今天下午看的课程，一些初级一班，到本周结束时，他们都会去深水区。他们大多数人会从跳板上跳下去，那有一米高。然后他们会游到梯子那儿。
Now most of them will not have anywhere near perfect arm stroke. Many of them will just kick to the ladder, but what that does is gives them-- with the head in the water again-- it gives them that confidence that if they should fall off a dock, they can look around underwater and kick or somehow get to the point of safety.
现在他们大多数人的手臂动作远达不到完美。他们许多人只会踢腿到梯子那儿，但这确实给予他们——头部再次没入水中——给予他们那种信心，如果他们不小心从码头上掉下去，他们可以在水下四处看看，踢腿或者以某种方式到达安全地点。
The second day, there was less crying. And by the second week, things had calmed down to the point where I started paying attention to the intermediate and advanced swimmers, kids mainly 8 to 12 years old swimming laps, all practicing the same slow stroke, reaching far out ahead and pulling slowly back, relaxed, breathing rhythmically, relaxed. They were learning to swim gracefully, gliding across the pool like schoolgirls walking with books on their heads. They were all learning to swim exactly like my wife.
第二天，哭的人少了。到了第二周，情况已经平静下来，以至于我开始关注中级和高级游泳者，主要是8到12岁在游泳池里游圈的孩子，都在练习同样的慢速划水，手臂大幅度伸向前方并缓慢地向后划，放松，有节奏地呼吸，放松。他们正在学习优雅地游泳，像头上顶着书走路的女学生一样在水池中滑行。他们都在学习如何完全像我妻子那样游泳。
He was strict. He was a strict teacher, but he's not mean. I mean, he used to say things like, "If you don't relax your hand, I'm going to break it with a hammer." But you knew that he wasn't being mean. That's just what he would say. He has a sense of humor, and as a kid, you know that. I think probably the most important thing about his teaching is that he does expect you to do it. And kids know what you expect of them. If you don't really expect them to listen to you, they know that.
他很严厉。他是个严厉的老师，但他不刻薄。我是说，他过去常说些话，比如：“如果你不放松你的手，我就用锤子把它敲碎。”但你知道他不是刻薄。那只是他会说的话。他有幽默感，作为孩子，你知道这一点。我想他教学最重要的一点可能是，他确实期望你做到。孩子们知道你对他们的期望。如果你并不真诚地期望他们听你的，他们知道。
Steven, I want you to fly. I want you to fly. Are you ready? Fly. Come on. Come on.
史蒂文（Steven），我要你飞翔。我要你飞翔。准备好了吗？飞。来吧。来吧。
The final part of the final lesson, Mr. Switzer took his beginning class to the diving board for them to jump and swim to the ladder.
最后一课的最后一部分，斯威策先生带着他的初级班去跳板，让他们跳下去并游向梯子。
This is the mostest of the funnest.
这是最最有趣的事了。
[CRYING] I don't want to.
[哭泣声] 我不要。
You want to do this, don't you? This is the fun. You want to do this, don't you?
你想做这个，对吧？这就是乐趣。你想做这个，对吧？
I don't want to.
我不要。
Colin, you want to do this, don't you?
科林（Colin），你想做这个，对吧？
I don't want to.
我不要。
Ready, one, two, three, jump.
准备好，一，二，三，跳。
And they all jumped, and they all swam. And then it was over.
他们都跳了，他们都游了。然后就结束了。
All right? You did a nice job.
好了吗？你做得很好。
Now our daughter Alice has a card saying she's passed the Beginner One level at the Switzer Aquatic School. Next thing I know, she'll be swimming far out into the lake at night. This is Scott Carrier.
现在我们的女儿爱丽丝有一张卡片，说她通过了斯威策水上学校的初级一等级。接下来我知道的，她就会在晚上游向湖中深处了。这是斯科特·卡里尔。
Act Three, Shooting Lesson. Well, my sister Randi has two kids, both boys. And she's the kind of mom who declared early on, no guns in the house. She thought it taught the wrong values. She's still your basic liberal soccer mom. As long as that phrase has come up in our national debate, that's my sister, soccer mom. But by the time each nephew, Ben and Sam, turned two years old, it became clear that the drive to play with guns, for whatever reason, was more powerful than one mom could stop. They would make guns out of anything. They'd make guns out of sticks. They'd make guns out of crayons. Once, we were having a spaghetti dinner, and I saw Benny make a gun out of a noodle. He tried to shoot someone with a noodle. Boys and guns, boys and guns.
第三幕，射击课。好吧，我妹妹兰迪（Randi）有两个孩子，都是男孩。她是那种很早就声明家里不准有枪的妈妈。她认为这教坏了价值观。她仍然是你基本的自由派足球妈妈。只要这个词在我们的全国辩论中出现，那说的就是我妹妹，足球妈妈。但当每个外甥，本（Ben）和萨姆（Sam）长到两岁时，很明显，玩枪的冲动，不管出于什么原因，比一个妈妈能阻止的要强大得多。他们会用任何东西做枪。他们用树枝做枪。他们用蜡笔做枪。有一次，我们在吃意大利面晚餐，我看到本尼（Benny）用面条做了一把枪。他试图用面条射击某人。男孩和枪，男孩和枪。
Well, Kitty Felde is a reporter who's best known to public radio audiences for her coverage of the O.J. Simpson trial, but not long ago, she headed out into the hills above Berkeley with her cousin's husband, a guy whose name is Jim Gray. And as you'd expect from a Berkeley area family, Jim Gray is the kind of liberal who would not go out with a big rifle on weekends shooting at game. He's not killing little rabbits and squirrels and stuff to feed the family or anything. He doesn't march on Washington to preserve our rights to assault weapons. He's not a member of the NRA. But even this liberal guy in liberal Berkeley, even he found a gun to love. And it turned out that it was a very particular kind of gun. It was a kind of gun that every time he showed it to another man, the reaction was always the same. The guy always said, "I want one of those too." It was a potato gun. In his front yard, overlooking sparsely populated hills, he gave Kitty a lesson in its operation.
好吧，凯蒂·费尔德（Kitty Felde）是一位记者，她最被公共广播听众熟知的是她对辛普森案（O.J. Simpson）的报道，但不久前，她和她堂姐的丈夫一起前往伯克利上方的山丘，那个人的名字是吉姆·格雷（Jim Gray）。正如你从一个伯克利地区的家庭所预期的那样，吉姆·格雷是那种自由派，周末不会带着大步枪出去打猎。他不杀兔子和松鼠之类的小动物来养家糊口。他不在华盛顿游行以维护我们持有突击武器的权利。他不是全国步枪协会（NRA）的成员。但即使是这个自由派伯克利的自由派，连他自己都发现了一把值得爱的枪。结果发现那是一种非常特殊的枪。这是一种枪，每当他把它展示给另一个男人看时，反应总是相同的。那个男人总是说：“我也想要一把那样的。”这是一把土豆枪。在他俯瞰人口稀少山丘的前院里，他给凯蒂上了一堂操作课。
Everybody in the neighborhood is making these?
附近每个人都在做这个吗？
Everybody in the neighborhood. This is my spud gun, a homemade spud gun made out of ABS sewer pipe. It's a piece of inch and a half ABS to a reducer that goes to a three inch ABS combustion chamber, female coupling and a male plug. The propellant is hairspray, which is the amazing part.
附近每个人。这是我的土豆枪，一种用ABS下水管自制的土豆枪。它是一截一英寸半的ABS管连到一个异径接头，再到一个三英寸ABS燃烧室，母接头和公插头。推进剂是发胶，这就是神奇的地方。
We'll get to that in a minute. Now this is-- who thought this up?
我们待会儿再说这个。现在这是——谁想出来的？
It was shown to me actually by a guy who's almost quasi-militia. His buddy showed it to him. They like to fire it at night for the blue flame. And I made one here. And instantly, all my neighbors had to have one. My neighbor right next door built one. But anyway, it has potatoes as ammunition. Cram the potato down the barrel It's actually a potato musket, also referred to as a potato cannon, but I call it the spud gun.
其实是一个几乎属于准民兵的人展示给我的。他的朋友展示给他的。他们喜欢在晚上射击它，看那蓝色的火焰。我自己做了一个。然后，所有的邻居都必须有一个。我隔壁的邻居也造了一个。但无论如何，它用土豆作为弹药。把土豆塞进枪管，它其实是一把土豆滑膛枪，也被称为土豆加农炮，但我叫它土豆枪。
You didn't use all of the potato there.
你没用完整个土豆。
Well, only that will fit in the inch and a half pipe. You have to use a potato that's bigger than the inch and a half pipe so that you totally fill the pipe up.
嗯，只有那一部分能塞进一英寸半的管子里。你必须使用一个比一英寸半管子大的土豆，这样你才能完全填满管子。
And now you're using this long dowelling.
现在你正在使用这个长销钉。
Yes, it's a ramrod, just as musket people use, pushing the wadding down into the barrel. The next step is three, one-second blasts of Aqua Net hairspray into the combustion chamber. Quickly putting the male plug in.
是的，这是一个通条，就像滑膛枪使用者用的一样，把填料推入枪管。下一步是往燃烧室里喷三下，每下喷一秒钟的Aqua Net发胶。快速塞进公插头。
He's screwing on the end to this plastic piping device.
他正在把末端拧到这个塑料管装置上。
Now watch this direction.
现在注意这个方向。
Oh wait, this is going to be really loud, isn't it? I've got to get back. This is too loud for my ears.
噢，等等，这会非常响，对吧？我得往后退。这对我的耳朵来说太响了。
Explain how you're igniting it.
解释一下你是怎么点火的。
Yeah, how are you igniting this?
是的，你怎么点火的？
This is a Coleman lantern igniter. You spin the gnarled end, and you get a spark on the inside.
这是一个科尔曼灯笼点火器。你转动粗糙的一端，里面就会产生火花。
Wait, I've got to back up. OK. Oh, and now the spud has taken a lovely arc, about 100 feet away, and has dropped behind the trees over there.
等等，我得往后退。好的。噢，现在土豆划出了一道优美的弧线，飞到大约100英尺远的地方，落在那边的树后了。
And that is totally useless. We just wasted a potato.
那完全没用。我们刚刚浪费了一个土豆。
Now what are you doing?
现在你在干什么？
Well, I'm using the vice grips to unfasten--
好吧，我用虎钳夹来松开——
It looks like a giant pair of pliers, about a three-inch wide end on the pair of pliers. You're unscrewing the coupling?
这看起来像一把巨大的钳子，那一对钳子末端大约有三英寸宽。你正在拧开接头吗？
That's true.
没错。
To reload?
为了重新装填？
To reload. It's a slow process. If you were being attacked by an army, you'd be dead by now.
为了重新装填。这是一个缓慢的过程。如果你正受到军队攻击，你现在就已经死了。
I would think the liability problems of having spuds landing in people's yards, perhaps on their bodies, would be a problem.
我想让土豆落在别人院子里，甚至落在他们身上，会是一个责任问题。
Yes, that's why we sort of do it secretly. Oh, a good one, a good one actually.
是的，这就是为什么我们偷偷摸摸做这个。噢，这一个不错，这一个真的不错。
I can't even see it.
我甚至看不见它。
Yeah, that was about 450 feet, something like that. That was a long one.
是的，那大约有450英尺，大概是这样。那是一个很远的一枪。
So none of the neighbors have complained about this? They've just asked, "How can I make one myself?"
所以没有任何邻居抱怨这个吗？他们只是问：“我怎么才能自己做一个？”
That's pretty much been the-- usually, it's a guy thing. It's a guy thing. And usually, I show it to the guys, and they instantly want me to either make one for them or show them how to make one. And I'd say there are at least half a dozen spud guns that have sprung from the original here. The legality of the thing is a little bit questionable. I've actually asked police, and the police wanted me to show them how to build one when I described it to them.
基本上都是这样——通常，这是男人的玩意儿。这是男人的玩意儿。通常，我把它展示给男人们，他们立刻就想让我要么为他们做一个，要么教他们怎么做。我想至少有半打土豆枪是从这最初的一把里演变出来的。这个东西的合法性有点成问题。我实际上问过警察，当我向他们描述它时，警察还想让我教他们怎么建一个呢。
If I can just jump in here for a second. So Kitty stands out there with her cousin's husband, and at some point a neighbor comes over. And they get to talking about all the improvements they're making in the spud gun. And as they talk, you start to realize the boy desire for gun and gun-ness is so powerful that these guys are gradually reinventing the gun. They are slowly turning the spud gun into a real gun.
如果我能插一句。所以凯蒂站在那儿，和她堂姐的丈夫在一起，某个时刻，一个邻居走过来。他们开始谈论他们对土豆枪做出的所有改进。随着他们的交谈，你开始意识到男孩对枪和“枪性”的渴望是如此强大，以至于这些人正在逐渐重新发明枪支。他们正在慢慢地把土豆枪变成真正的枪。
Well, as soon as I showed it to my neighbors, they decided to do design improvements. They tried increasing the size of the combustion chamber. They tried decreasing the size of the combustion chamber. They tried putting a valve in so they could inject pure propane as opposed to the hair spray to get a more explosive mixture. They tried different materials for the gun itself. And here comes Tom with a couple of version two with a longer barrel. Let's go talk to Tom.
好吧，我一把它展示给邻居，他们就决定进行设计改进。他们尝试增加燃烧室的尺寸。他们尝试减小燃烧室的尺寸。他们尝试装上一个阀门，这样他们就可以注入纯丙烷而不是发胶，以获得更具爆炸性的混合物。他们尝试为枪本身使用不同的材料。看，汤姆（Tom）带着第二版的改进型来了，枪管更长。我们去和汤姆谈谈。
So, Tom, this is the Mach 2 version?
所以，汤姆，这是Mach 2版本？
Yeah. We've decided that the longer barrels don't really make any difference. Both Jim and I have tried shooting next to each other. Both have about the same range. We've also used propane as opposed to hairspray. That doesn't seem to matter either.
是的。我们认为更长的枪管并没有什么区别。吉姆和我都尝试过并排射击。射程都差不多。我们也用过丙烷代替发胶。那似乎也没什么关系。
Whoa, that had nice arc to it. Very nice arc.
哇，那弧线不错。非常好的弧线。
I took it to job site, and the roofer was up on the roof, roofing. And I fired it off, kaboom. We were up on a hillside. It arced way out there, and the roofer poked his head over and said, "You've either  got to make me one or show me how to make one."
我把它带到施工现场，屋顶工人在屋顶上修屋顶。我把它发射了，砰。我们在山坡上。它划出了一道长长的弧线，屋顶工人探出头说：“你要么得给我做一个，要么教我怎么做一个。”
So is there a name for this loose-knit organization of spud gun owners?
所以这个松散的土豆枪持有者组织有名字吗？
Well, not yet. We're actually trying to avoid any-- we're hoping not to be considered a group. We don't want the attention of any law enforcement agencies that might track us down and consider us militia or some other weird--
嗯，还没有。我们实际上在努力避免任何——我们希望能不被认为是一个组织。我们不想引起任何执法机构的注意，他们可能会跟踪我们并认为我们是民兵或其他奇怪的——
I mean there's no unifying political.
我是说没有任何统一的政治目的。
There is absolutely no unifying political. No, this cuts across the spectrum from liberal to conservative, nothing unifying politically at all about these things. It's a guy thing. That's all there is.
绝对没有任何统一的政治目的。不，这跨越了从自由派到保守派的所有领域，这些东西在政治上没有任何统一之处。这是男人的玩意儿。就是这样。
Kitty Felde.
凯蒂·费尔德。
Act Four, Found Tape. Well, our program today is about lessons. And when we turn to John Connors, a guy who helps us find music for our program, for songs, when we ask him for songs, he said that it turns out that there are lots of records that are lessons of various types. In fact, I've got a whole big bunch of them here that he gave us. Here's one on wine from a guy-- "How do I know which wine to serve at dinner, Mr. Seashell? Which is a vintage wine, and what is the difference between vintage and non-vintage?" Well, this record right here answers the questions on that. Here's Bazaar's "Secret formula for a beautiful new you."
第四幕，现成录音带。好吧，我们今天的节目是关于课程的。当我们转向约翰·康纳斯（John Connors）时，那个帮我们寻找节目音乐的人，当我们向他要歌时，他说，事实证明，有很多唱片本身就是各种类型的课程。事实上，他给我们的那堆唱片里有一大堆。这是关于葡萄酒的——“我怎么知道晚餐该选哪种酒，海螺先生？什么是年份酒，年份酒和非年份酒有什么区别？”好吧，这就张唱片回答了这些问题。这是巴扎尔（Bazaar）的“美丽新我的秘方”。
But I have to say, the favorite of our little radio staff is one that defies all normal description. Let's just go to it, shall we?
但我必须说，我们电台小职员最喜欢的一张 defy 了一切正常描述。让我们直接听听吧，好吗？
Hello, I'm Helen Gurley Brown, and I wrote a book called Sex and the Single Girl. I had so many things left over to say, not necessarily to single girls, but to married girls and men, that I'm putting some of them on this record. There's so much to cover, really, that I think we'll just move right along. Let's start with some advice to men on how to have an affair.
你好，我是海伦·格莉·布朗（Helen Gurley Brown），我写了一本书叫《性和单身女郎》（Sex and the Single Girl）。我还有很多话要说，不一定是对单身女孩，而是对已婚女孩和男人们，所以我把其中的一些话放在了这张唱片里。真的有太多内容要讲了，我想我们还是继续吧。让我们从给男人的一些关于如何出轨的建议开始。
Now, I'm not for promiscuity, but I think it's ridiculous to pretend that it doesn't exist. And I think there's far less hurt and more joy for everybody if certain rules are followed. The way not to have an affair start, in my opinion, you're a married man, is to run to the girl and say, "Honey, my wife's taken the kids to the country. The coast is clear for you and me." The fact that this is a convenient time for you has absolutely nothing to do with the situation, It certainly isn't any aphrodisiac. It might even be more flattering to the girl if your wife were in town.
现在，我并不提倡滥交，但我认为假装它不存在是荒谬的。我认为如果遵循某些规则，大家的伤害会更少，快乐会更多。在我看来，已婚男人的出轨方式不是跑去跟那个女孩说：“亲爱的，我老婆带孩子下乡了。现在只有我们俩。”这对你来说是个方便的时间，这跟情况完全没有关系，这绝对不是什么催情剂。如果你的妻子在城里，对那个女孩来说甚至可能更受宠若惊。
Another thought, on the first date, don't suggest that obscure little lobster house 50 miles up the coast, which you think is delightfully quaint. She knows what you're doing. You're hiding her out. In the beginning at least, be sure you go first class.
另一个想法，第一次约会时，不要提议去海岸上50英里外那个你觉得非常古雅的隐蔽小龙虾屋。她知道你在干什么。你在把她藏起来。至少在开始时，确保你去的是一流的地方。
All right, let's say the affair is on. How do you keep her happy? Never assume the physical relationship is the all out rewarding thing for her that it for you. It just isn't. Even if she does enjoy your beautiful, bronzed body-- and you know she does-- this is America. She's a nice girl. She's this product of what her mother and her grandmother told her, and they probably told her never to do what she's doing with you.
好吧，假设出轨已经开始了。你怎么让她快乐？永远不要认为那种肉体关系对她来说像对你一样是一种全面的奖励。事实并非如此。即使她确实享受你那美丽、晒得古铜色的身体——你知道她享受——这是美国。她是个好女孩。她是她母亲和祖母告诉她的产物，她们可能告诉过她永远不要和你做她正在做的事情。
Also, her body needs to have a baby. A lot of men offer her sex, not your superior brand of course, but what she'd really like to hear from somebody is an offer of marriage. Presents take the pressure off, so do give them. Money is a perfectly wonderful present. You know, it isn't half as insulting as you'd like to think. A nice share of General Motors, or a US E bond, tucked in with a bottle of Arpage, really are very hard to take offense at.
还有，她的身体需要一个孩子。很多男人向她提供性爱，当然不是你那种卓越的品牌，但她真正想从某人那里听到的是婚姻的提议。礼物可以减轻压力，所以一定要给。金钱是一份非常美妙的礼物。你知道，它并不像你想象的那么侮辱人。一份通用的股票份额，或者一张美国储蓄债券，塞进一瓶Arpage香水里，真的让人很难产生反感。
Don't expect your girl to share your wish not to be seen or to keep the lipstick off your collar. That's your responsibility. Maybe it sounds perverse, but a girl may actually take a certain offbeat pride in being seen with somebody else's attractive husband. If you do run into friends of the family, don't try to burrow your way to China. Just smile and be gracious and introduce everybody all around if you're trapped. No explanations and no apologies.
不要指望你的女孩分享你不愿被看见或者不愿让衣领上留下唇膏的愿望。那是你的责任。这听起来可能很变态，但女孩实际上可能对与别人的有魅力的丈夫一起被看见有一种不寻常的骄傲。如果你确实遇到了家里的朋友，不要试图钻进地洞。只要微笑并表现得优雅，如果被困住了，就把大家介绍一番。不要解释，也不要道歉。
Never drink up her booze without replacing it. You really ought to bring a lot more than you consume. Never, never, never let her spend her birthday alone, even if you have to lie your way into purgatory to get out of the house. Never lie to her about little things. The big lie you're living, that someday the two of you are going to be married, is going to be hard enough to explain when the time comes. Be sure she can trust you in smaller matters. Treat your girl with great dignity, like a princess. Never, never cheat on her with anyone but your wife.
永远不要喝光她的酒而不更换它。你真的应该带来的比你喝掉的多得多。永远、永远、永远不要让她独自度过生日，即使你必须谎话连篇才能从家里溜出来。永远不要在小事上对她撒谎。你正在过的那种巨大的谎言——总有一天你们会结婚——到那时会很难解释。确保她在小事上能信任你。用极大的尊严对待你的女孩，像公主一样。永远、永远不要除了你妻子之外，和任何人一起欺骗她。
The record is called Lessons in Love , Helen Gurley Brown. Some of the other little sections on here, "How to love a man if you aren't pretty, black magic for non-glamour girls." "It works too," it says. "Unfaithful wives' tales, how they out-cheat their unsuspecting mates." "How to love a boss, ways a girl can make herself invaluable, keeping him happy and her fire-proof." "How to talk to a man in bed." And let's see, "Little man, you'll have a busy day. You can be especially successful with women if you're short." And here's this one.
这张唱片叫《爱情课程》，海伦·格莉·布朗。这里面还有一些其他的小部分，“如果你不漂亮该如何爱男人，非魅力女孩的黑魔法”。“它确实有效，”上面写着。“不忠妻子的故事，她们如何胜过她们毫无戒心的伴侣。”“如何爱上老板，女孩如何让自己变得不可或缺，让他快乐，让她防火。”“如何在床上和男人说话。”让我们看看，“小男人，你会度过忙碌的一天。如果你很矮，你在女人身上会特别成功。”还有这张。
Now I want to talk about secretaries. A secretary offers the only kind of polygamy we recognize in this country, the chance to have a second wife at the same time you have your first one and not go to jail. If you select her carefully, she can be the loveliest of all fringe benefits. And to think, the company pays for her. Turning your secretary into a girlfriend has one big advantage. You know where she is most of the time. If that's what you want, then I suggest you just follow the preceding rules about getting any other girl to the brink and keeping her happy after she's there.
现在我想谈谈秘书。秘书提供了我们在美国承认的唯一一种一夫多妻制，即在拥有第一任妻子的同时拥有第二任妻子的机会，而且不会坐牢。如果你仔细挑选她，她可以成为所有附带福利中最可爱的一个。想到公司还支付她的薪水。把你的秘书变成女朋友有一个很大的优势。你大部分时间都知道她在哪里。如果这就是你想要的，那我建议你遵循前面关于让其他女孩达到临界点并在此后让她快乐的规则。
However, I'm inclined to go along with the Broadway musical number that says a secretary is not a toy. Why not let one of the other guys at the office hire the gorgeous girl for a secretary, and then you borrow her for whatever you had in mind. And that way, you can keep your own secretary to do more important things like running your life and bolstering your ego and protecting you and mothering you and covering for you and sending out for sandwiches. If the the girl who should be doing all that is a ravishing redhead that you're off your rocker about, you'll wind up doing those things for her.
然而，我倾向于赞同百老汇的一首音乐剧歌词，说秘书不是玩具。为什么不让办公室里的其他家伙雇那个漂亮的女孩当秘书，然后你再为你的意图借用她呢。这样，你就可以保留自己的秘书去做更重要的事情，比如管理你的生活、支持你的自尊、保护你、照顾你、为你掩护以及去买三明治。如果那个应该做所有这些事的女孩是一个你为之疯狂的迷人红发女郎，你最终会为她做这些事情。
Besides, all romances end, or they end in marriage, and you'd soon be out of a secretary again. If you want to play it smart and have your secretary love you and stay with you a long, long time, then follow these rules. Bring her presents from your trips, a baby--
此外，所有的罗曼史都会结束，或者以婚姻结束，你很快就会再次没有秘书了。如果你想聪明点，让你的秘书爱你并和你在一起很长很长时间，那就遵循这些规则。从你的旅行中给她带礼物，一个孩子——
All right, all right. Let's see. Let's move on, shall we, in our little collection here?
好了，好了。让我们看看。让我们在我们的收藏中继续吧，好吗？
We sincerely hope this record will be helpful in teaching your parakeet to talk. Remember that your bird is an imitator and learns to talk by listening to what you say, not only words and sounds, but inflections. Don't say, "Good morning." Say, [INFLECTING] "Good morning."
我们真诚地希望这张唱片能对教你的长尾小鹦鹉说话有所帮助。记住你的鸟是个模仿者，并通过听你说的话来学习说话，不仅仅是单词和声音，还有语调。不要说，“早上好。”要说，[语调上扬]“早上好。”
The beautiful thing about this particular record is that it is so much more than just practical how-to. It doesn't just give you the important advice like, be diligent, pick a time every day to speak to your bird, make sure you're not trying to talk to your bird when he's eating, drinking or playing. It encourages you. It tells you how to take the right tone. And then it offers proof.
这张特定唱片的美妙之处在于，它不仅仅是实用的操作指南。它不仅给你重要的建议，比如，要勤奋，每天选一个时间跟你的鸟说话，确保你在跟鸟说话时它没有在吃东西、喝水或玩耍。它鼓励你。它告诉你如何采用正确的语调。然后它提供证明。
There are people who still doubt that a parakeet can actually talk. So we have recorded here the voice of one Chicago parakeet conversing with his owner. He is six years old and has a 400-word vocabulary.
有些人仍然怀疑长尾小鹦鹉是否真的能说话。所以我们在这里录制了一只芝加哥长尾小鹦鹉与主人对话的声音。它六岁了，有400个单词的词汇量。
[PARAKEET CHIRPING]
[长尾小鹦鹉鸣叫声]
Hello, everybody.
大家好。
What is your name?
你叫什么名字？
Peter. Peter talk.
彼得（Peter）。彼得说话。
Where do you live, darling?
你住在哪里，亲爱的？
1400 Lakeshore Drive, Chicago.
湖滨大道1400号，芝加哥。
I think you're wonderful. Do you want some breakfast?
我觉得你太棒了。你想吃早饭吗？
Yes, sir.
是的，先生。
It's really just amazing what they can get animals to do today. Well, that's from our little collection.
动物现在能做的事情真是太令人惊奇了。好吧，那是我们收藏中的一段。
Well, our program was produced today by Peter Clowney and myself, with Alix Spiegel and Nancy Updike. Contributing editors Paul Tough, Jack Hitt, and the fabulous Margy Rochlin.
好吧，我们今天的节目由彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）和我自己制作，还有爱丽丝·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）。特约编辑保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）、杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）和出色的玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢名单]
Production help from Jorge Just, Julie Snyder, [? Amy Takahara, ?] Sylvia Lemus, Todd Bachmann, and Consigliere Sarah Vowell. To buy a cassette of this program, call us  here at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380. Well, you know you can listen to most of our programs for free on the internet at www.thislife.org. Thanks to Elizabeth Meister, who runs the site.
制作协助：豪尔赫·贾斯特（Jorge Just）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、[艾米·高原（Amy Takahara）？]、西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）、托德·巴克曼（Todd Bachmann）和幕后顾问莎拉·沃威尔（Sarah Vowell）。如需购买本节目的录音带，请致电我们在芝加哥的WBEZ电台，312-832-3380。好吧，你知道你可以在互联网上免费收听我们大部分的节目，网址是www.thislife.org。感谢运行该网站的伊丽莎白·迈斯特（Elizabeth Meister）。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台（PRI）发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who recorded this at a recent staff meeting.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生（Mr. Torey Malatia）负责，他在最近的一次员工会议上录制了这段话。
It's the mostest of the funnest.
这是最最有趣的事了。
I don't want to.
我不要。
You want to do this.
你想做这个。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week, if we have the courage, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来，如果我们有勇气的话，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。